this has happened before and it's
happening again and in fact we've
covered this before on presidential
election days video has caught an
electronic voting machine switching
votes and we now have at least three
reports of this happening in at least
two different Mississippi counties based
on the latest information and this could
still change this was the Republican
gubernatorial primary runoff we have one
video of it for you posted to Facebook
by Sally Kate Walker which shows a man
attempting to vote for Bill Waller and
the machine selecting instead Tate
Reeves multiple times as the person taps
the screen so a few things here this
particular video is from the Burgess
voting precinct in Oxford and the same
machines that are in use there are in
use in lots of the state of Mississippi
the Secretary of State's office has put
out a statement saying they're aware of
the issue and they dispatched a
technician as soon as they were told
about it this was a tsx machine it's
owned by the county it was tested by
local officials two machines in Calhoun
County have reportedly shown similar
vote switching behaviors so ok this is a
Republican gubernatorial primary runoff
they're fixing it what happens if this
takes place on presidential election day
in November of 2020 when turnout is
higher when the stakes are yes they are
higher even though of course we want
every election to be secure when one
precinct or a group of precincts could
conceivably turn a state and one state
could conceivably decide the
presidential election what do you do now
as of right now there's no reason to
think that this is foul play this is
most likely the screen being
miscalibrated so when you tap on a part
of the screen it's interpreted as you
tapping on a different part of the
screen it's simple enough but it's
potentially 110 percent chaotic on
Election Day if one wanted to manipulate
an election you only need to interfere
with some portion of
machines in some portion of precincts in
just one or two states and you can
hypothetically turn the results of a
presidential election and this is where
the left and right are truly different I
talked so many times on the show about
there's lots of areas were left and
right or basically the same perpetuating
the status quo there are other areas
areas where Democrats and Republicans
are very different when it comes to
sexual harassment by people within their
party Democrats and Republicans are very
different when it comes to net
neutrality Democrats and Republicans are
very differently Republicans have made
it clear for more than a decade now they
are simply not super concerned with
election interference election tampering
voter suppression etc as long as their
candidate wins and they understand that
a lot of this stuff helps the Republican
/ the Democrat helps the more
conservative Republican / the more
moderate Republican within Republican
primaries but in principle they don't
care as long as they benefit from it in
some way shape or form the left on the
other hand we just want 100% secure
elections we want everyone who wants to
vote and attempt to vote to have their
vote counted and the reality is of
course that the left benefits from
greater turnout and more votes being
counted because the country has moved to
the left there's no you know the right
will say well you guys just want more
people to vote because it helps you
that's right I want the highest level of
participation in the system that we have
with the understanding that the will of
the people will be most accurately
reflected when as many people as
possible actually go out and vote when
the right hears about this stuff they
say well both sides do it even when it's
not totally clear that something is
actually being done and when you zoom
out it is far more red states that have
the electronic voting machines with no
paper trail which if one wanted to
tamper with an election through the
voting machines that have no paper trail
it would be a really great
place to start so this is again just
another one of the many anecdotes of
this taking place it's not presidential
election day but we all understand the
risk here or at least we should
understand the risk here what's the next
step with these particular voting
machines I don't know but these types of
voting machines are in use in a lot of
the United States